- Hi, everybody!
It's Monday!
(audience applauding)
- Drew!
- Gosh, I love Mondays!
Hi, everybody, welcome to the show.
There is so much to talk about today.
There are so many stories to cover.
You know, Andy Cohen actually said to me,
"You are a walking mood board,"
and to that, I said, "Yeah, accurate."
And when I thought about the
show we were gonna make today,
it felt like a mood board.
We wanna talk about Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
We have Ross Matthews here to
discuss last night's Emmys.
We have Jose Andres here to speak
about the life-changing
good that can be done
in the world of food.
We have Paris Hilton,
who is in a different place in her life,
and she's opening up
to us about all of it,
and I am truly able to connect with her
about something very
unique that we both share.
So, hello, VFFs. Hi to you at home.
(audience applauding)
Thanks for being with us.
We're gonna get right into our news,
and we're gonna do it in our style,
serving it sunny side up.
It's time for "Drew's News."
- Yeah!
(audience applauding)
(tires screeching)
(car crashing)
(cat shrieking)
(dramatic music)
- Excuse me, sir! Ma'am, guy!
Tell me your story!
Ma'am, I asked you a question!
This is "Drew's News!"
This is "Drew's News."
It's "Drew's News."
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Hi, well, we're gonna get right into it
because for the first time ever,
at-home prime-time Emmys was last night,
so we got to do "About
Last Night: Emmys Edition."
(Drew snaps fingers)
(audience cheering)
(camera shutter clicking)
All right!
Oh, I love the paparazzi sound effect.
Here to help us is Emmy winner himself,
the lovable and effervescent,
even at 6:00 a.m. L.A.
time, Ross Matthews.
Hello, Ross!
(audience applauding)
- Well, hello!
Hi!
- Oh, Ross, I love
when you stepped into all
of our lives with Jay Leno,
and you've really just been
someone that every time we see,
you're smart, you're funny,
we love your take on everything.
You make the world a better place.
- Oh, I might just wake up at 5:00 a.m.
every morning for you here in L.A.
if you're going to talk
like that, sweetheart.
- Ross, I will always
make it worth your while.
And have you slept?
Because you won a third Emmy last night.
(audience applauding)
(Drew cheering)
- "Ru Paul's Drag Race," we won again!
Let me tell you, look at
that. It is unbelievable.
I love award seasons.
They're like my Christmas,
my Easter, my Thanksgiving.
Ever since I was a little kid,
my mom bought me an old red
towel at a thrift store,
we put it on the front porch,
and I used to pose on it
and pretend I was on the red carpet.
And now, Drew, look at life!
It's amazing.
- I love that!
Well, illuminate us
with all of your wisdom.
We have to talk about "Schitt's Creek."
I mean, they schwepped-
(audience chuckling)
I mean, every category.
They won everything.
And just when you were
about to kinda be like,
"All right, spread it
out, share the love,"
the Levys would come and do these speeches
that were so gracious and incredible.
You're like, "You know what?
You just take everything.
You go right ahead. Have it all."
- Well, listen, people
kind of heard of the show.
It got some big Emmy
nominations last year,
and I think in quarantine,
it was like the perfect show to binge.
And that also happened to be
when everyone was voting on awards,
and that party, the fact
that they were all together.
I kind of was so happy for
'em, but also was like,
"Can anyone get an appetizer around here?"
Every two seconds, I've got
to stand up and make a speech.
(chuckling) But it really was so great
to see this little show that
could with comedy legends
winning a historic seven, all
big, all in seven categories.
- I also think that
when it's a last season,
it's like, "We wanna celebrate
your entire board vision
of legacy that you've
left in the entire show."
So, well done.
Listen, I love Ramy Youssef.
He had like Jeff Spicoli attire,
which is something I totally relate to.
And then he put this out on social,
which I thought was hilarious.
This is what happens when
you don't win the Emmy,
and the guy in a hazmat suit
just has to kind of walk away.
- Because they were
delivering all the Emmys,
just like this.
Like Uber Eats, this was Uber Emmys.
where they just brought it
(Drew laughing)
to their houses.
But, I mean, please don't take it away.
Can you just wait in the car?
If I'm not gonna win, I
don't want to see it, okay?
- It was like, this is how
you lose the Emmys in 2020.
Wait, we have to talk about Zendaya,
who is just one of my favorite
people on planet Earth
for every reason in the world.
And her win was history last night,
or herstory, as we're saying now.
Yeah, I finally got that one.
- Yeah, good for you.
- And it took me a
minute to learn herstory.
But she's the youngest person
ever to win lead drama.
- 24 years old. She is the youngest.
She's only the second
African American woman
after Viola Davis.
Now, listen, the previous youngest winner,
it was Jody Comer last year, who was 26,
won for "Killing Eve."
- [Drew] Oh.
- What I loved Zendaya's
speech is that she talked
about the young people
in the streets right now,
thanking them for keep fighting.
And just looking at her with
that Emmy virtually, at home,
it was just such a 2020 moment,
like such a time capsule right now.
- And her, not to be shallow,
but her fashion couldn't
have been more on point.
She is a walking mood board
of sort of how one can express themselves.
And I just think she's so deserving
and such an inspiration
for the next generation.
And then I'm just gonna end it on,
I have to go out on the
laugh, Alex Borstein.
I was like, "Wait, what is going on here?
Why is she doing this?"
But I was so into it!
I'm like, "I like weird,"
and she really gave it up.
- Let me tell you something,
she is #mood for all of us right now.
It's like, all I want to do
is be in like a silk robe,
and some champagne,
laying on a chaise lounge.
Can I just live that life?
- I just thought, "Thank you,
you gave me some eye candy,"
and this was sort of odd,
and the whole thing was
very unique and interesting.
And I don't know where we go from here,
but I appreciated what Jimmy Kimmel
and everybody did last night,
and I thank you for being here to recap
what's happening with the Emmys 2020.
And congratulations, Ross!
- Thank you, my love!
Thank you so much.
It was so great to have
the Emmy's last night.
The world feels crazy, and
it felt like a little piece
of almost normal last night,
so thank you.
- That's why we got
right into it today, so
thank you for helping us.
I love you, and please come back ASAP.
- I promise I will. Thank you, my love.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
♪ Hey, oh, oh ♪